hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast tough targets simple
genotyping new solutions for CRISPR
mitochondrial disease neurology and
pharmacogenetic research presented by
Dana Pfister Sullivan product manager at
cannon biomedical I'm Christy Jewell of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
cannon biomedical for more information
about our sponsor visit WWN nao medical
comm before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
now if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing this presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you can use
the Q&A button to let us know you're
having a problem please join me in
welcoming this is Dana Pfister Sullivan
I will now turn the presentation over to
her Thank You Christy for that very nice
introduction today I'm excited to
present on the topic that Christy spoke
about tough targets simple genotyping
new solutions for CRISPR mitochondrial
disease neurology and pharmacogenetics
this is a quick agenda slide of the
topics I'll be going over today today
I'm going to discuss Cannon and genetics
selecting a genotyping technology for
your tough targets HRM screaming and
CRISPR I'm going to talk about
mitochondrial disease and novo allele
neurology targets specifically apoE and
alzheimer's pharmacogenetic tests and
finally I'm going to talk about how you
can find your ATAR
today so let's get started with Canon
and genetics as I'm sure not all of you
know that Canon has entered into this
field if that's you you may be thinking
why is can Annette laberd's is this the
same Canon who offers cameras and
printers the short answer is yes however
we are a smaller subsidiary of that
larger parent company the next question
you could ask is will do you offer
cameras for my microscope or some sort
of medical imaging the answer here is
actually no but today I will discuss
what we do offer before I do that I
would like to start a poll so this is
the first poll today I'm going to be
doing a couple polls throughout this
presentation to keep it interactive with
you guys this first one is just to see
who out there is familiar with canon
biomechanical you'll be given three
choices so you have yes you have
I've heard of Canon but not in the
biomedical field and you have no and I'm
going to give you guys all a little bit
of time to answer this question for me
so again the poll should be popping up
on your screen you should see the
question you should see the three
answers and you should be able to answer
it accordingly and I appreciate your
time to do that
and so I'm just gonna give you guys a
couple more seconds okay thank you so
much so for those of you that are
unfamiliar with cannon biomechanical it
is a new subsidiary of cannon the cannon
has always been interested in the
biomedical field in fact sorry some
technical difficulties here my screen is
not changing slides there we go in fact
our first cannon president who's
pictured here was a doctor he actually
developed a new x-ray imaging device for
screening tuberculosis in the 1940s in
Japan when the disease was infecting
millions of individuals and current
diagnostic x-rays were not cutting it
I think his interest in helping fellow
men and women comes from cannons
philosophy Chios a which you can see on
this slide which is all people
regardless of race religion or culture
harmoniously living and working together
into the future this philosophy often
drives Canon when making business
decisions and I think you can agree that
it can easily be applied to the
biomedical industry and human health
that brings us to now cannon is choosing
to go back to its roots
however while imaging for Diagnostics
has fallen slightly behind there is this
shift for a more molecular approach so
in March 2015
Canon USA launched Canon biomedical a
subsidiary responsible for canons life
science and molecular diagnostic
products and in September of that same
year we launched our first commercial
life science products our research use
only Nova Leal genotyping assays which
will be the main topic for today before
I dive into more details about our
assays I would like to discuss why you
would want to choose noble for detecting
your tough targets
that brings us to our second poll this
poll is a two-part poll so the first
question I'm going to ask you guys is if
you genotype human samples currently and
here you can the poll should have
appeared on your screen so the question
is do you or does your lab currently
genotype human samples and you'll have
three options you'll have yes/no book
planning to do so soon and by soon let's
say six to eight months and then the
other option is no and then once you
answer this question like I said it will
be a two-part poll so the next question
will be if you answered yes what
technology do you use so I'm going to
give you guys a few seconds to answer
this first question
and now you should see a second question
appear and if you answered yes you'll be
able to answer the second question which
is which technologies are used in your
laboratory for genotyping and there's
some common technologies here that I'll
talk about in the next couple of slides
but that is hydrolysis probe PCR
next-generation sequencing Sanger
sequencing a microarray mass
spectrometry HRM or perhaps other
okay thank you so much for taking the
time to answer those polls so I think
it's easy to agree that there are many
things we must consider when you find
yourself needing to genotype and there
are different situations that may
require you to do so on this section on
the right you will see three of these
situations where you may need to
genotype a sample for example you might
be pre-screening so maybe you are
selecting a sample to include or exclude
from a larger study the second situation
here is screening so it's basically the
opposite it's a more retrospective
approach a good example of this might be
screening gene edits or CRISPR clones
for a specific mutation and I will go
into more detail about that later in
this presentation and then lastly you
could be verifying something maybe
you're verifying something that you have
already learned from a different method
so for example you could have sent out a
sample for full genome sequencing and
you want to verify a specific target
that came back and so when choosing a
genotyping technology it's important to
know what type of mutation you are
searching for so it could be a single
nucleotide polymorphism you could be
looking at DNA insertions or deletions
maybe you're looking at somatic
mutations where you're doing copy number
research or methylation research and
depending on that type of variation or
variations you're investigating you will
most likely choose a specific technology
so while those are the needs of
researcher might have I think it's fair
to say you have options for one you have
to consider the experiment for example
are you trying to discover new new
mutations and perhaps looking for the
unknown or are you testing for a
specific mutation sample number and
sample amount can also weigh on what
sort of technology you want to use and
lastly you may consider your resources
not just the amount of people or tech
missions you have and their skillsets
available but also the budget and costs
towards your genotyping efforts for
example do you want them to spend their
time on genotyping methodology that
requires a robust knowledge of
bioinformatics analysis or would you
rather those resources be applied
elsewhere how quickly do you need your
answer and so after a researcher weighs
all of these questions they then decide
on a technology to use here you can see
some of the methods that they can choose
from there's next-generation sequencing
which is a more whole genome approach
there Sanger sequencing a classical
approach mass spectrometry hydrolysis
probe PCR and then there's two PCR based
approaches like hydrolysis probe PCR
commonly referred to as pac-man and high
resolution melting high resolution
melting is a more targeted approach it
offers a broad selection of targets it
can detect what might be considered
tough or difficult targets it allows you
to test one sample at a time and it can
even verify a multi target
discrimination and what I mean by that
is when there are multiple snips that
are close to one another
high resolution melting can distinguish
those snips in one test the technology
is fast in most cases it can be run
within an hour but in some cases even
less it can be run on an open platform
and data analysis is scalable and can be
very straight forward due to the
availability of controls because of
these advantages that HRM offers cannon
biomedical uses technology to develop
and launch their novel genotyping assays
these assays have a very simple
four-step protocol the first step being
DNA extraction followed by sample
preparation which requires mixing the
assay the sample or a control with our
high speed
Oh genotyping Masterman next is to run
those reactions on an instrument with
fluorescent detection that supports HRM
most real-time PCR instruments have HRM
capability and I will be providing an
example of those later in this
presentation
the last step is to analyze the data
most instruments support HRM analysis
but we also offer no real controls that
help make the analysis even easier by
comparing sample melt curves to those of
the controls to call a sample genotype
but what targets are supported by HRM
many targets are supported by HRM
including single nucleotide
polymorphisms small insertions and
deletions and what I mean by that are
those that are less than 6 base pairs or
so but unlike hydrolysis probe PCR HRM
can also detect much larger deletions so
those greater than 200 base pairs and we
even offer some assays in our portfolio
that detect over seven-and-a-half
kilobases
each arm can also detect mitochondrial
DNA targets which I will discuss in a
few slides and HRM can also support
somatic mutation copy number and
methylation
however we currently do not offer any
products supporting these types of
targets so in the next couple sections I
would like to discuss where you can use
novalee Olave in your genotyping
research specifically in this section I
want to discuss how HRM can be
implemented into CRISPR clone generation
research before I do so I have another
poll for you again this is a two-part
poll so I'm going to this first part of
the poll should show up just about now
and the first question is are you using
CRISPR in your lab today or planning to
begin to use it soon and so your answers
can be yes I'm using CRISPR now I plan
on implementing it soon and once again I
think what soon
and six to eight months and then the
third option is you do not use or you
have no plans to implement the use of
CRISPR so I'm going to give you guys a
few seconds here to answer this question
and so depending on your answer if you
answered yes or if you're planning on
implementing it soon another question
will appear on your screen now and that
is how you are using CRISPR and your
research so your answer could be
something like I'm screening cell models
for specific mutations or maybe you're
doing drugs you're doing discovery based
research or perhaps you're doing both so
again this second poll is now appearing
you should be able to see the three
options and I'm going to give you a few
seconds to answer those questions
all right thank you so much and again I
really appreciate you guys being
interactive with me today so I'm sure we
can all agree the crisper is a hot topic
as I'm sure you're aware crispers and
newer simpler technology often used for
genotyping for genome editing and it
does create genetic variance for
background purposes CRISPR does have two
main components one being guide RNA and
the other being caste 9 a DNA and a
nucleus the the guide RNA determines
where insertions or deletions may occur
and directs caste 9 to bind to that area
caste 9 will then break the
double-stranded DNA and repair and
repair that DNA in one of two ways the
break can be repaired by non-homologous
end joining or homology directed repair
non-homologous end joining can produce
insertions and deletions being here of
variable lengths and is much more random
whereas homologous directed repair seen
here has the ability to be more specific
and introduces precise point mutations
or insertions by way of a donor template
seen on the right so these two
mechanisms for CRISPR repair can create
challenges for gene editing and when
creating CRISPR clones
researchers need to screen a clone
population to see which ones acquired
the mutation or variation of interest
and due to the to repair mechanisms not
all clones will have that specific
mutation there are limited downstream
screening options for CRISPR clones
because CRISPR is introducing genetic
variation genotyping techniques are
often implemented into the screening
process current methods include gel
based cleavage kits however this can be
considered slow they do lack sensitivity
and they are very hands-on another
option
to design your own primer a PHA or a
self primer design though this does
require significant expertise and it can
be time-consuming due to the need of
optimization and lastly you can you sing
or sequencing however this does take
time it often requires samples to be
sent out and it is more costly than the
other two options but what about HRM it
is useful for detecting genetic variants
as well and as it turns out scientists
have accepted HRM as a simple and
effective way to screen for CRISPR Drive
mutations in fact the group from Harvard
recently published a protocol in Cold
Spring Harbor protocol on how to use HRM
for detecting endo mutations caused by
CRISPR and in 2017 that same group
published a paper using the method they
tested 30 individual cells for the
presence of mutations using HRM they
found that HRM was an effective method
to identify fully mutant clone another
group out of university of alabama
published a similar study and found that
HRM was highly efficient at detecting
CRISPR derived mutations in zebrafish
they used HRM for rapid and efficient
identification of nucleus derived
mutations to help advance cost-effective
high-throughput methodologies for
mutation detection in this chart here
they break down the results from their
HRM analysis on four different CRISPR
targeted genes seen here here here and
here and they show that HRM was able to
detect all cells with a drive mutation
100% of the time the noble genotyping
assays use HRM to detect snips and
indulge for clinically relevant variants
here you can see how the data analysis
from these assays easily make clear what
variation
has been created which is an advantage
that might not be as clear using other
methods of variant detection in this
case the black curve seen here is the
homozygous wild-type the red mount curve
seen here is the homozygous mutant and
the blue mount curve is the heterozygous
variant now I would like to move to
another example where HRM can be used in
detecting tough targets specifically
mutations in the mitochondrial DNA so
why might that be tough well we have to
consider the difference between nuclear
DNA and mitochondrial while there are
two copies of nuclear DNA there are
greater than 1000 copies of mitochondria
in the cell mitochondrial DNA is
maternally inherited and has a much
higher mutation rate in fact 10 to 17
fold higher than nuclear DNA and there
has been more than 250 pathogenic
mitochondrial DNA mutations that have
been identified but why does that matter
well as you probably know mitochondria
are the energy Factory of our body when
you taste occur mitochondria can fail to
produce enough energy which can cause
disorder or mitochondrial diseases
symptoms of these diseases can be found
on the slide but they are often
neurological problems such as dementia
muscle weakness mental retardation
learning disabilities etc and common
detection methods for these these
targets are next-gen sequencing and
Sanger sequencing but once again these
can be costly and time-consuming because
of this we developed hmmm based assays
that target specific mutations in the
mitochondrial genome that are associated
with some of the more common pathogenic
mutations
these are MuRF Neos and LH o N and their
associated diseases can be found in the
for a column of the slide seen here our
published research has found that HRM
mitochondrial DNA detection is as as
sensitive as the common methods and it
can detect heteroplasmy which I'll
discuss in more detail shortly it is
also a viable alternative to the more
costly and labor-intensive options this
is one example of the data from a meal
offing the muons assay detect mutations
in the Milosz gene you can see some
information about the target on the left
side of the slide but what I really want
to focus on here is the data found on
the right this is an unlabeled probe
assay so there is a tall peak seen here
on the far right that represents the
full sized amplicon and there are
smaller Peaks on this side of the graph
that represent the probe amplicon hetero
duplex these smaller curves distinguish
the three genotypes and here you can see
the wild-type is in black the homozygous
mutant is in red and the heterozygous
state is in blue this is an example of
another type of assay specifically a
small amplicon assay unlike the assay we
saw before this assay has one peak and
that distinguishes the genotype this
assay detects a snip in the LH o n gene
which is which is associated with levers
disease and that can cause vision loss I
mentioned how to replace me before but
detecting mitochondrial DNA becomes even
more complicated due to the hetero
plasmic nature of the mitochondria
genome it is very possible for only some
of the mitochondria to have a mutation
in the presence of how to row plasma the
ratio of wild-type to mutant DNA
determines the onset of clinical
symptoms furthermore it has been shown
that a minimum critical portion of
mutated mitochondrial DNA is needed
before this function becomes apparent
in other words the more mutant the
mitochondrial genome is the more the
phenotype could be affected our research
has found that the assays we offer can
detect mitochondrial DNA mutations
between nine and thirteen percent of
mutant DNA depending on a mutation and
therefore can detect mutations even in a
hetero plasmic population where only a
portion of the mitochondria contain the
mutation I just showed you how HRM can
be used to detect mitochondrial DNA and
now I would like to show you other
targets again detect in this section I
will discuss some neurology targets we
offer cannon biomedical offers over 80
target specific to neuroscience and
associated neurological diseases on this
slide you can see a handful of targets
we offer and the specific diseases they
associate with today
I want to talk specifically about our to
a Poe a targets for Alzheimer's for
those of you that don't know a pony is a
gene that encodes for April lipoprotein
II which is responsible for maintaining
cholesterol levels because of this it's
often associated with diseases of the
heart such as a heart attack stroke
hypertension or coronary heart disease
but what it is most associated with as
Alzheimer's disease we offer two
specific apoE assays that help
distinguish a polio wheels
there are three common a poly alleles
they are a PO 2 3 & 4
a poly 3 is the most common allele and
is found in more than half the
population and considered the wild-type
the two assays we detect I'm sorry the
two assays we offer detect snips in the
apoE gene seen here
and here that cause an amino acid change
based on the variation or mutation so if
you look at the chart if a sample was
wild-type for both assays that we offer
that sample could be categorized as a
poies three if the sample was mutant for
both it could be categorized as apoe4 it
has been shown that the disease risk for
Alzheimer's depends on the person's
genotype these disease risk seen on this
slide were pulled from the Alzheimer's
drug discovery Foundation website again
the III allele is the most common allele
and contains the average risk the apoe4
allele increases this increases an
individual's risk for developing late
onset Alzheimer's and the apoE two
allele is the least common allele in the
population this next slide shows data
from blood samples using one of the apoE
assays i just spoke about you can see
that it easily just differentiates the
genotype by this recurse however on the
right you can also see that by using our
noble oil control sets so in this graph
here the that you can compare the sample
data seen here and here to the new to
the noble oil control curves in blue
this makes it easier easy for
researchers to have and find a positive
control and their genotyping HRM
experiments and we offer positive
controls like this for most of our
genotyping assays the last example today
that i want to focus on is our
pharmacogenetic offerings cannon
biomedical offers over 90 genetic
targets specific to pharmacogenetic
research on this slide there are a few
examples of those you can see the
targets the variant type and the
specific drug interaction
today I want to focus on three of these
in particular so two to six to six to
see nine targets and 1z Kor see one
target in the section I want to discuss
a particular study that was recently
published earlier this year from
University of Florida in the study the
lab compared three genotyping solutions
for these three specific snips
associated with warfarin metabolism the
researchers compared our noble
genotyping assays pac-man hydrolysis
probe assays and with separates based
pyrosequencing by cryogen they looked at
both blood and saliva samples and tested
these three mutations a mutation and the
vko rc1 gene will cause warfarin
resistance a mutation in the SIF 2c9
start to reduces metabolism by 30% and a
mutation and the stars real sieve to c9
reduces metabolism by 90% this slide
shows the genotyping data for the blood
samples the overall concordance was
greater than 99% I do want to point out
that there was one sample that was
determined to be homozygous wild type
for the vko rc1 gene by both de novo
liase and the pyrosequencing method
however that same sample was
undetermined by pac-man this slide shows
the HRM melt curves for those three
targets with blood samples you can see
the variants are easily distinguishable
again the wild-type is shown in black
the homozygous mutant is in red and the
heterozygous samples are in bloom this
slide looks really familiar to the last
five we saw however it shows the
concordance of the data in saliva
samples the overall concordance in
saliva was 100% but again
pac-man failed to determine one of the
samples
this time a heterozygous sip to see nine
stars three sample this slide shows the
HRM curves for those three targets with
saliva and you can see how they are
easily distinguishable the wild-type is
shown in black the homozygous mutant
once again is in red and the
heterozygous sample is in blue overall
the researchers found that HRM analysis
is a fast and cost-effective reliable
method to detect a wide range of
mutations and the comparison proved the
synovial assays are reliable compared to
the two common options before I conclude
I want to quickly show you how you can
find your targets of interest today
this slide here breaks down the products
that we offer in our Neuville portfolio
that I've discussed I apologize for it
being a little bit blurry for you guys
we do offer four different things so we
have the noble genotyping assays which I
spoke about the noble control sets the
noble oil genotyping master mix and the
2x Noble all ago dilution buffer and I
do want to quickly mention that if you
have your own primers and probes you can
pair them with our noble genotyping
master Maxine here and our two X
although dilution buffer to implement
our high fast speed chemistry that I've
spoken about today the products are
shipped at ambient conditions and the
assays in the master mix can be stored
at four degrees Celsius the control
should be stored at minus twenty and
each assay offers 166 reactions for a
ten micro litre reaction in the
beginning of the presentation I showed
you a protocol that requires an HRM
capable thermo cycler
an oval chemistry can be run on any HRM
capable thermo cycler however we have
tested and validated market leading
instruments found on
is slide you will see common instruments
and some maybe even found in your lab
such as bio-rad CFX 96 and 384 roches
light cyclers thermo fissures or a bi
quad studio and cryogens rotor gene cue
platform again I have to apologize that
this slide is a little blurry but if you
are interested in seeing the type of
targets we offered outside of the ones I
discussed today in the presentation or
if you want to learn more about the
targets that we offer you can visit our
website at
www.extracareanimalhospital.net
[Music]
it would bring you to a page similar to
this and you can find your catalog
number for the assay and the catalog
number for the Associated control for
that assay on this page in this red box
here and then if you continue to scroll
down you can see example data curves for
doffing
again you can visit us at wkbt el
medical comm the products are available
in the US direct from canon biomedical
and via our distributors in Canada
Ireland and United Kingdom you can also
email us a contact us at canon -
biomedical comm to discuss your tough
targets and how noble can help before we
get to questions I would like to
summarize by saying that I hope now you
can see how HRM & Noble can help detect
your toughest targets
HRM detects a variety of targets and
those of which we talked about today are
snips in Dells rare alleles and
mitochondrial DNA and Noble delivers a
bench validated simple protocol with
rapid results that is cost effective
it offers genotyping controls so you are
not limited to sample number and can
test as little as one sample at a time I
urge you to reach out today to see how
neuville can help detect your toughest
targets one last obligatory slide with
disclaimers that I just have to share
with you guys so these products like I
said are research used only if you want
to learn more about the product you can
visit our website seen here that also
contains user guides and product
specific information and I do want to
mention that Nova oil is a trademark of
Canon biomedical with that I'm happy to
answer any questions you may have thanks
for hanging in there with me today I
sincerely appreciate your time
Dana thank you for that informative
presentation as you mentioned we will
now start on the live Q&A portion of the
webinar now to our audience members if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay let's get started then our
first question is is this offered as
servus so it's a really great question
and we actually get that a lot
the products are sold as reagents only
to be used with an HRM compatible
instrument that you have in your lab we
do know that often people do reach out
to gene typing core labs to get their
results and we do urge you to talk if
you're interested in this technology to
talk to your core labs about this but
right now these products are just sold
as reagents and they are not offered as
a service here at canon biomedical you
know what if you don't have my target of
interest so if we don't have your target
of interest or if you go to the website
and you search in the discovery areas or
the assay database you can always
contact us directly to see how we can
help so again that contact information
that I shared on the past slide and I
think it's here too is contact us at
Canon biomedical comm but we are
releasing new assays regularly and a lot
of our assays that we choose to launch
actually are coming from suggestions or
requests from customers so please do not
hesitate to email that contact us at
canon biomedical comm to discuss your
tough target here's another question can
you multiplex using these products so
that's another very good question that
we sometimes get the assays use one die
only so with unlabeled and with
unlabeled primers and probes so they are
not multiplexed but they are optimized
for high speed reactions and we have
seen that on some instruments the PCR
followed by melt can be completed in
close to twenty twenty-five minutes
similar targets often have the same run
conditions and so they can be run on the
same plate but again these are not they
cannot be multiplex now okay thank you
here's a great question and it's two
parts first part what
the best sensitivity of HRM and can I
use HRM to detect somatic mutations
that's another great question so
research has shown that the sensitivity
for HRM can be as high as 100% and it's
usually shown to be between 90 to 100%
and most of the literature I've read in
the literature that we've published here
atrium can be used to detect somatic
mutations
however the products that we currently
offer do not detect somatic mutations
very good Thank You Dana I believe that
is all the time we have for our question
and answer session today thank you again
for this informative presentation do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we close I just want to thank
everyone for listening to my
presentation today and I hope that you
saw how noble could help answer finding
and genotyping your toughest targets
thank you so much Christy I really
appreciate it and thank you Dana we
really appreciate your time today I
would also like to thank lab roots and
canon biomedical for making today's
educational webcast possible now before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye